brothers and sisters helped me on this
new project to sponsor 50 orphans
brothers and sisters inshallah it's 600
pounds a year but I wanted every one of
you guys to get involved by giving even
if it's one pound please get involved
now inshallah and help us sponsor 50
orphans for an entire year
check out our sponsors Nature's Blends
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code salam10 for 10 of
their products and I'm going to pick on
someone called Nas daily yeah recently
he done a video I'm gonna do a specific
video for him here I'm so sorry I'm
going to call him a coward he's a
Palestinian who identifies as a
Palestinian Israeli
are you you're not Israeli you're not
Israeli but you're Palestinian Are you
ashamed of yourself
huh yeah because people who are silent
are as good as those who are bombing
babies into pieces Israel that's what
they're doing and the International
Community and the media after pressure
BBC getting reported to offcome and
complaints finally uh doing something
now you can see how it really looks that
way yeah when the media do their damn
job you see how it how real the things
are anybody that says there's a conflict
happening here like this
shame coward nastina you Shameless man
you did a recent video about some guy
who sells his life yeah this is the only
benefit about someone who basically
basically steals his life this is the
first person in the world to sell his
life he is the first publicly traded
human yeah
um people buy shares in his life Israel
is buying shares in your life he's they
could they're buying you the controlling
I'm not saying to directly fund you what
I'm trying to say is that why are you
not speaking up when thousands hundreds
of babies are being blown into pieces
you coward you coward you have millions
of views you get on Facebook you YouTube
and you YouTube you're damn silent you
are damn signing you coward yeah speak
about you're supposed to be Palestinian
yes shame on you shame on you no more
good assumptions then BS not anymore
okay so that's it brother sisters send
this video to Nast daily make sure you
send it to him make sure nothing will be
more pleasing to me nothing will be more
pleasing to me for him to watch this
video and hear with his own ears yeah
shame on you as a Palestinian yeah
Palestinian Israeli yeah shame on you
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself yeah stand up for the people
who've been oppressed
till next time